we finished the paper and we thought we
have this really quite nice result and
so we submitted that to the journal I
knew that we were going to have this
problem because I had had a similar
problem before when I wrote a paper
which we entitled cosmic Springs and the
journal was submitted to wrote back
saying this is very nice piece of work
but the title won't do and we had to
make it a very technical title so I
thought this might happen and anyway we
submitted it off but within an hour of
submitting it to Physical Review the
editor who was in charge of it wrote
back it was a quite a funny reply way he
wrote as far as I know the Beatles have
made no contribution to the field of
cosmology and Vettel he was telling
telling us to get rid of all references
to George Paul Ringo and John okay so
this is a paper that I've recently
written with their two colleagues here
at Nottingham and another colleague in
France and the title of the paper is
general second order scalar tensor
theory self-tuning
and the Fab Four so obviously the
curious bit about that is a bit of the
end which is the Fab Four which does
refer to John Paul George and Ringo and
four lads from my hometown that went on
to form the Beatles this is a is a
serious scientific paper it presents a a
solution or a possible solution to one
of the most difficult problems in
physics which is the cosmological
constant problem and as I said we're
trying to solve this this this very
difficult problem we started with
something very very general and we
managed to really reduce our Theory down
to four key elements and so it was given
how difficult it was and how general it
was in the beginning the fact that
reduced to four very simple key elements
on stage we thought it was seven so we
called in the Magnificent seven but then
we actually realized that three of those
were we're sort of trivial so we seven
became four well I'm from Liverpool so I
was born in the same hospital as John
Lennon and so you know it's kind of
close to my heart these are our sort of
four key elements of the theory which is
this is this sort of really what
describe the theory you know have to
worry about you know what this means but
as you can see we've named them John
Paul George and Ringo okay so yeah so we
sent it off to the to the journal and it
immediately came back without having
been assessed by by any any experts just
saying there's no way we're going to
publish a paper with all these
references to the Beatles in it in view
of the Beatles limited contribution to
cosmology so what happened next is
basically we had to change it we had to
cave in really we didn't have much
choice in the matter there because it's
important to get these papers into
journals and the scientific content is
certainly good enough to manage that so
we just had to call John number one
Paul number two George number three and
Ringo number four which is it not quite
as colorful the Fab Four lives on
because in certainly in our field of
research the way that we submit papers
now it's kind of a dual process and in
particle theory you submit your papers
once you've finished them you submit
them to an electronic archive and that
electronic archive every day gets
updated with new papers and then you can
you can submit that the paper you've
sent to the archive you can also submit
it to a journal for refereeing so we
submitted it to the archive and it's
living on the archive and it's
downloaded and it's been referenced
quite a few times it's kind of n I've
done and actually we're going to write
another paper on this subject and there
will certainly be referring to is the
fact for so it's set in stone now and
there one day the journals are just
going to have to accept that George
Ringo Paul and John don't appear in the
one submitted to the journal but apart
from that they're the same we've we
haven't changed anything else academic
papers are very serious important things
and this sounds like some pretty serious
highbrow work why would you put joking
something funny out why do you do it in
the first place I mean because we're a
fun group we enjoy our work back if you
don't enjoy your work go and do
something else and a lot of money doing
something else we for us it's and it you
know the calculations we've done are
correct as far as we know and they're
they're all done very seriously and week
we got together on a regular basis all
of us to discuss it and check things and
it was towards the end that we realized
there were these four terms emerge then
we just when you when you're writing
your notes you just rap and calling them
ABCD we thought well let's call them
let's give them the name
so we're trying to and basically attack
the cosmological constant problem which
is probably the hardest problem of the
most embarrassing problem in physics
today we look out and neat in a universe
around us and imagine you you took out
all the planets and all the stars the
universe would be empty but it wouldn't
mean that it had zero energy it would
have what we call a vacuum energy well
we can see the effect of the vacuum
energy on on the expansion of the
universe so one thing that vacuum energy
will do to universe's expansion is it
will it will cause its expansion to
accelerate the space the space itself is
getting bigger but gravity is an
attractive force so strictly speaking an
attracted for attractive force will slow
down an expansion that's not what's
happening that's not what we're seeing
and one of the explanations for that is
that it's actually vacuum energy that's
causing it to accelerate so what what
the vacuum energy does is it turns that
deceleration into an acceleration so the
big question is where does vacuum energy
come from whoa well the vacuum the
vacuum energy comes in a vacuum but then
you can't you look at particle physics
and you say okay let's try and count
what we think the vacuum energy should
be we can observe what it is but let's
try and work it out from first
principles you look at say the electron
and you see that the electron
contributes some vacuum energy from it
has its own vacuum and here it
contributes some energy to the vacuum
all the other particles do the same and
when you add all this up you realize
there's a huge mismatch between what you
expect to see and what you actually see
so what people some people expect is
that for example that actually the the
vacuum in T is zero but perhaps quantum
Corrections give you a very small vacuum
and this would be the dream some
symmetry in nature take the vacuum
energy to zero and quantum Corrections
make it sort of slightly you know
slightly just above zero for example but
this is very very hard to do to find
that symmetry that takes you to zero
vacuum energy in the first place that's
what we've set out to do we've set out
to try and try and find that and our
starting point was was really we started
looking at the way gravity behaves so
to try and understand how gravity
behaves is that you think of it from a
particle physicists point of view I mean
we often talk about gravity as being
curvature of space and time that's like
it's like at the relativists view of
gravity I want to think of this from a
particle physicists point of view and
what gravity is or what any force is
actually is the exchange of virtual
particles so we exchange particles so
the earth is exchanging particles with
the Sun you and I Brady we are there's a
graph small gravitational attraction
between us and there we are exchanging
virtual particles these are called
gravitons now you can't just grab a
graviton you know just at some point the
grabs onto we're exchanging you can't
just grab it right it that there
virtually no you can't just isolate one
like that
well we said what would happen if you if
something else helped to mediate the
gravitational force so there wasn't just
exchanging these gravitons they were
exchanged of other particles too so we
took a simplest scenario which is that
you the gravitational force comes from
the exchange of these gravitons plus
what we call a scalar particle and this
is just a particle that has no
directional dependence it's very simple
the Higgs particle looking for at the NH
LHC that's an example of a scalar
particle so we ask the question what's
the most general theory describing
gravity then involved exchange of
gravitons and this scalar what's the
most general theory you could write down
and we're to our surprise we discovered
that some obscure PhD student in the in
the air' 70s had actually found this and
guy called han deskey he'd actually
discovered what this theory was now it
was very complicated how he wrote it and
when we discovered this we were thinking
of a similar thing but we decided to do
a search to see if anyone had done
included this scalar field and we found
on disk his work and it was written down
in quite a complicated way it's a big
long expression can this theory solved
the cosmological constant problem are
there corners of this theory that solved
the cosmological constant problem and so
we asked that question and we said right
let's let's essentially put this theory
through our cosmological constant
problem filter let's demand
this theory can solve it so essentially
it gives us that extra symmetry that
solves the cosmological constant problem
and out popped the Fab Four it's
remarkable we had such a horribly
complex theory really complex theory and
out popped these four very simple sort
of building blocks to what what is a
solution essentially to the cosmological
constant problems there they are the
building blocks for this symmetry that
allows you to set that vacuum energy to
zero they're terms that are arise in
explaining the theory there's four key
terms that's why the four are there
there's a lot more to test for example
we need to test that they can give a
viable cosmology not just that they can
you know D gravitate the vacuum energy
but that actually they can give us a
viable cosmology you know over a long
period I like this one I like it not
least because we had great fun doing it
and we're still working very actively on
it but it's a nice idea I think I really
think it's quite a nice idea it may all
collapse I mean it could be that when we
begin to work out quantum Corrections to
this the whole thing breaks down on it
not only that we need to be able to get
reproduce the gravity gravity we see in
the solar system and that's not trivial
that you to do this but but actually the
fact that you've got these gradients
here might help in that regard let me be
upfront about the the actual solution
that we this thing eventually goes to
doesn't seem to be quite what we're at
today but what it provides you with is
an initial way of getting rid of the it
problem of this big cosmological
constant and that's the that's the key
ingredient